[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
très heureux de vous retrouver en direct
sur france 3 bourgogne première grande
conférence de presse des manuels macron
à l'elysée jeudi soir devant près de 300
jeunes journalistes durant deux heures
et 23 minutes ces annonces très
attendues après trois mois de grands
débats et plus de cinq mois du mouvement
des gilet jaune ouvre-t-elle un nouveau
chapitre du quinquennat le chef de
l'état a infléchi t-il sa politique élu
citoyen gilet jaune ont ils été entendus
les réponses apportées par emmanuel
macron sont elles à la hauteur des
attentes des français
ou bien ce grand débat at il finalement
accouché d'une souris on en débat
justement ce dimanche avec nos invités
elle sa merci et bonjour vous êtes
membre des gilet jaune en saône-et-loire
merci d'être avec nous tout comme
d'ailleurs jean bernard l'habile bonjour
vous avez également membre de gilet
jaune en saône et loire
face à vous pour vous répondre et
débattre françois patriat bonjour bon je
vous êtes sénateur de la côte-d'or
président du groupe la république en
marche au sénat merci d'être là
jean-françois farag bonjour vous êtes
maire de blanot et président des maires
ruraux de saône-et-loire merci à tous
d'avoir accepté cette invitation vous
qui nous regarde et vous pouvez bien sûr
commenter cette émission en direct avec
le hashtag dit mme paul bourgogne alors
je vous propose de commencer avec une
image c'était hier après-midi dans les
rues de dijon
cette image c'est celle d'une
manifestation de gilet jaune
on y est habitué il y en avait également
du côté de la roche de solutré hier et
puis il y en avait aussi à strasbourg et
à paris avec une question pour vous
françois patriat jeudi emmanuel macron
devait être apporté des réponses et hier
après midi il y avait encore des gens
dans la rue dans plusieurs villes de
france
il y avait hier trente mille gilet jaune
dans la rue hier bien est-ce qu emmanuel
macron s'est adressé aux gilets jaunes
s'est adressé aux français ou français
élégie léger les journées français les
jaunes sont des français bien entendu
ils représentent aujourd'hui un
pourcentage de français
trente mille à manifester dans la rue et
hier je reconnais le chiffre même 40000
si on veut mais il est français c'est
quand même beaucoup plus que les gilets
jour d'aujourd'hui il ya des jeunes des
parents des retraités tout le monde il
ya aussi par new delhi les genres les
alors de là
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont l'air un
peu déçu quand même on va venir sur le
fond et sur les différentes propositions
dans un instant mais d'abord première
chose ça n'est pas vrai si on prend les
quatorze mesures proposées par le chef
de l'état une par une
elles sont plébiscités la retraite à
1000 euros dans trois ans plébiscité la
réalisation des retraites plébiscité il
ya maintenant la non fermeture des
hôpitaux plébiscité le statut des mers
demain l'ebit cidre ou de la mer et 20
po 1 sur 20 retravaillés manuellement
millions de français plébiscitent et
seulement l'objet le chef de l'état
apporte case réponse justice fiscale
justice sociale justice territoriale
ça ne répond pas et je comprends à
toutes les demandes des gilets jaunes ce
que jenny assène jean débat a d'ailleurs
par don ni à celle du grand débat parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de propositions de
grands débats qui n'ont pas été retenus
et vous imaginez bien que le chef de
l'état n'avait pas apporté hier entre
500 et 1000 réponses aux grands débats
hilario il a repris à la suite du
synthèse de grands débats cat est fait
avec le premier ministre les éléments
essentiels concernant à la fois l'école
où plus de fermetures de classes
c'est que décollent mère d'école sans
l'accord du maire plus de sherlock
holmes plus de fermeture d'hôpital
on sait ce que ça veut dire mais selon
l'insee l'acquis sans l'accord du maire
il ya quand même des avancées
significatives qu'il faut qu'on peut
examiner ensemble je me sens mieux
reprendre tout mais je voudrais qu'on va
et on va y venir aux propositions dans
un instant mais d'abord d'un point de
vue général vous êtes toujours dans le
mouvement des gilet jaune elle sa merci
ça veut dire que ce que vous avez
entendu jeudi d'une manière générale on
va rentrer dans le détail dans un
instant ça ne vous a pas convaincu ça ne
vous a pas satisfait ça ne répond pas
aux attentes des gilet jaune
ban à monsieur le président de la
république parle d'une révolution
profonde et d'un changement un
changement aussi grand et n'a jamais été
fait dans notre république et sur
certaines mesures ça peut s'entendre
ça peut s'entendre mais pour moi
globalement non c'est pas
révolutionnaire c'est pas
révolutionnaire il ya certaines choses
qui sont quittes y ont été plébiscités
comme la proportionnelle par exemple ça
fait partie des choses qui ont été
plébiscités quoi le sentiment d gilet
jaune quand vous êtes retrouvés pour
écouter le président de la république su
jean bernard laville ccd sus et choquée
s'est énervé c'est le temps de pommes à
des miracles du maroc donc oui c'est
compliqué ça allait me raconter quand
même ça reste quand même un peu oui
parce qu en fait les principaux sujets
qui intéressaient les gens d'abord s'est
et c'est ce qu'ils ont dans leur
assiette
et puis ensuite le hérissé l'aiglefin
démocrates y est le mot d'ordre et de
démocratie
alors justement jean france afin qu'on a
on a parlé des maires dans cette
conférence de presse le président la
république a parlé des mers alors que
dans le début de son quinquennat il vous
avait un peu laissé de côté vous aviez
ouvert vos mairies vous aviez fait des
cahiers de doléances vous avez tous les
uns et les autres
organiser des grands débats et alors est
ce que ça vous satisfait au global au
global il ya plutôt une satisfaction
quand même de la part des maires parce
qu'effectivement ils ont été plusieurs
fois cité et je la dois zid en asie les
maires sont essentielles donc ça a été
clairement dit il a dit aussi donc il
que la commune était quelque chose
d'important témoin j'ai peut-être
l'impression que la commune est sauvée
parce qu'on était quand même depuis
plusieurs années sur un mouvement de
détricotage de la commune avec des
compétences qui partait et puis le le
rôle de proximité du maire qui
s'affaiblissait donc ça c'est plutôt une
belle évolution
le fait aussi que le maire doivent
valider la fermeture de l'école ou celle
de l'hôpital c'est aussi une mais des
propositions une belle chose et c'est
dans les cahiers de doléances que vous
avez ouvert ou d'or après organisé est
ce que est ce que les gens s'y
retrouvent
alors après bon il ya des annonces de
principes qui sont faites et sur le côté
de la démocratie locale et puis du rôle
de la commune je pense quand même que
tout reste à tout reste à préciser parce
que on en est resté quand même au
dernier loi aux dernières lois la loi
note la loi la loi la loi du 3 août 2010
8 quelqu'un qui a quand même été votée
en 2018 alors certes par l'assemblée
nationale
au final la qui dépossède les communes
de certaines compétences vous attendons
les éclaircissements sur beaucoup de
dents en avant un éclaircissement sur un
certain nombre de points
on va continuer ce débat je vous propose
d'abord d'écouter le président la
république avec les principales annonces
qui nous sont résumées par muriel
rousselet emmanuel macron la répéter pas
de changement de cap
je crois que les transformations en
cours et les transformations
indispensables à faire dans notre pays
ne doivent pas être arrêté le président
écarte le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne lui préférant un référendum
d'initiative partagée plus ouvert est ce
que je souhaite c'est que dans le cadre
de notre réforme constitutionnelle nous
puissions aller plus loin sur le
référendum d'initiative partagée qui a
été créée il ya maintenant 11 ans dans
notre constitution
on en simplifiant les règles en
permettant que l'initiative puissent
venir de citoyens un million de citoyens
qui signerait une pétition et qu'elle
puisse prospérer en projet de loi et si
elle n'était pas examiné par les
assemblées aller au référendum
la suppression de 120 mille postes de
fonctionnaires n'est plus une priorité
le président souhaite renforcer les
services publics au plus près des
citoyens avec des maisons des services
publics dans chaque canton
emmanuel macron ne veut pas toucher à
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite même
s'il veut inciter à travailler plus ce
sur quoi peut travailler le gouvernement
avec le parlement c'est de regarder si
on peut allonger la période de référence
sans bouger l'âge légal pour avoir un
système de décote qui incite à
travailler davantage
le président a confirmé que les
retraites les plus modestes seront
indexés sur l'inflation
avec l'instauration d'une pension
minimum autres annonces la baisse des
impôts et la création d'un conseil de
défense écologique
emmanuel macron s'est dit également
favorable à la suppression de l'ena
l'école nationale d'administration
alors il ya plus de cinq mois le
mouvement des gilets jaunes étaient nées
autour de la question de l'augmentation
des taxes du carburant et du prix du
carburant en général les questions de
pouvoir d'achat du site fiscales sont au
coeur des débats
elle sa merci est ce que vous vous dites
on a quand même réussi à faire bouger
des lignes parce que le président dit je
reste droit dans mes bottes j'ai fixé un
cap je vais le tenir parce que j'ai été
élu pour ça et on le comprend et en même
temps on voit qu'il ya des inflexions
très nette qui si vous n'étiez pas
descendus dans la rue à un moment donné
ne serait peut-être jamais arrivé sur la
table je peux je peux accorder c'est ces
mesures est pour moi mais
on va prendre là on a juste relever les
prix du carburant donc en 2017 il était
à 1,17 et là bon je fais le plein là ce
matin il à 1,44 oui on est déjà sur la
taxe carburant je dis rien eu de fait il
ya rien eu d'annoncé mais la réalisation
des petites retraites c'était s'était
par exemple un devoir indications ça je
pense que monsieur patriat pour à nous
répondre peut-être plus précisément
parce qu'en fait la réindexation a été
invalidée par le conseil constitutionnel
en fait il s'agit d'une souche
indexation des retraites de plus de 2000
euros donc en fait c'est quelque chose
qui était déjà en cours déjà prévu est
déjà plus ou moins valides et invalides
et donc c'est ça je veux dire je mets de
côté parce que pour moi c'est pas une
annonce alors la baisse de l'impôt sur
le revenu je continue à essayer de
développer les les choses qu'ils ont sur
leurs tombes où j'ai quand même chez sur
le revenu l'impôt sur revenu en france
et l'un des impôts les plus
redistributif c'est un des impôts les
plus justes en fait un conte à 1 ou
demander une baisse de la tva
voilà qui est un impôt qui n'est pas
juste et qui est par exemple sur le
carburant on a des taxes qui sont axées
on à double taxation
donc il ya plein de choses qui sont
incohérentes la baisse des impôts bomba
fou soit mais quand on a dans la
question numéro trois du grand débat
pour réduire le déficit faut-il baisser
les dépenses ou augmenter les impôts ou
les deux ou je ne sais pas pour moi
c'est très très fermé quand même ce qui
est bien sauf que si l'on peut optimiser
l'efficacité aussi de ski en plein sauf
que ce qui est intéressant c'est que
emmanuel macron je vais donner la parole
à françois patriat dit par contre la
question des du nombre de fonctionnaires
n'est plus un préalable
et je peux revoir la copie là dessus
parce que les français attendent autre
chose de notamment une proximité des
services publics sur la question de la
tva
est-ce que l'impôt sur le revenu c'est
finalement la chose la plus facile a b c
est pourquoi est ce que c'est une
question idéologique la question de la
tva
je voudrais vous rappeler quand même que
il ya plus de 50% des français qui
payent pas d'impôts qui payent pas
d'impôts oui c'est léger saint paul et
peluches et légitime
oui c'est eux aujourd'hui le moindre
atout alors la tva tva.b six mois
j'étais hostile à la baisse de la tva
sur les produits de première nécessité
pourquoi ce style pourquoi parce que
d'abord
vous passez par là que l'accord de
l'europe pour le faire aujourd'hui on a
droit à trois jeux de mots tendres notre
produit donc mais là c'est déjà un débat
européen
on peut encore le régler mais au bout du
compte ça va profiter à qui est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la baisse de la tva sur
la restauration a profité à quelqu'un
non parce qu'à chaque fois pour battre
la tva
d'abord sur les produits de première
nécessité on le fait comme ça mais ce
sont les transformateurs les industriels
et les distributeurs et de la marge et
qui augmente douala pendant qu'on ait de
quoi m'attendre mais cette année on est
dans une économie de marché ne pas
d'économie administrée soirée êtes
communiste y est vous l'avouer très bien
si vous êtes un système communiste
administrés vous ne l'êtes pas donc on
fait pas ça donc voilà donc comme c'est
quelque chose qui 1 ne profite pas à
ceux à qui devrait profiter d'eux qui
moi j'étais partisan à titre personnel
j'ai attendu mais j'aurais peut-être
préféré un système qui considèrent à
dire voilà si on avait baissé les
produits de première nécessité pour les
gens ça représente quoi 20 30 euros par
mois net euros par mois la tva va
peut-être parade par la caf donné tous
les trois mois
à ces gens là où transferts entre la caf
les parents organisme social
la série qui n'ont pas droit aux aides
sociales ils sont tout juste au niveau
des purs verser le chèque à tout le
monde
c'est ce que tout le monde ya toujours
un moyen par les impôts pour tout le
monde par les services fiscaux monneron
donne toi ô combien on donne bien
aujourd'hui
non non ça n'a pas été retenu ce chef de
l'état a retenu aujourd'hui la hausse
la hausse du travail qui paie avec la
prime d'activité avec la baisse des
cotisations sociales et des cotisations
chômage par ailleurs il l'a fait il a
retenu la baisse d'impôts d'abord pour
les classes les plus défavorisées pour
les classes moyennes il le fait c'est de
la justice fiscale à côté d'un effort
autour dit c'était pas cotisé pacotille
et bien moi 10 milliards mois de
décembre 8 milliards yard près de 20
milliards non mais ça fait combien
d'années maintenant mise en place
n'avait ça non mais c'est vague qui va
falloir trouver dans le lui dire alors
il ya deux catégories de gens il ya ceux
qui vous disent oh là là mais 20
milliards
ça y est c'est le tournant c'est le
tournant du laxisme qu'on a fait avant
comment va-t-on les financiers on pourra
pas les finances et bien ceux qui vous
disent à côté mais 20 milliards c'est
rien du tout c'est peanuts
il ya 80 milliards de 200 milliards de
division fiscale parents savoyards entre
les deux je crois que le gouvernement a
choisi celui de la 7e
de la raison et de l'efficacité je veux
que ce pays soit réforme paraît et qu'on
a qu'on dise pas le déficit public
on parlera tout à l'heure des questions
de démocratie locale etc mais sur ces
questions de fiscalité pouvoir d'achat
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que le
présent la république a répondu aux
attentes de vos administrés ce pouvoir
d'achat moi je voudrais réagir surtout
sur la question des retraites et je
pense que c'est quand même une urgence
sociale parce que moi je le vois dans le
dans le monde rural
vous avez des agriculteurs les retraites
agricoles notamment qui sont aujourd'hui
à 700 euros et pour des gens qui ont
travaillé parfois 40 ans où ils sont et
leur heure et qui n'ont pas compté leurs
heures 7 jours sur 7 et du soir au matin
du matin au soir plutôt je pense que la
retraite à mille euros c'est quelque
chose là pour ces gens là notamment etc
etc est urgent mais sur lequel il ne
faut pas attendre alors la mesure la
mesure est bonne et elle est mise en
péril des gens pour la mettre en place
et je trouve qu'il faut beaucoup de
temps pour le mettre en place entre les
artisans aux professions dites il ya
quand même des priorités des priorités
des urgences qu'il faut traiter alors
c'est bien que lé été bus parce que de
toute façon il ressortait dans le grand
débat mais il faut y aller tout de suite
a laissé sa françois patriat on supprime
d'un coup d'un seul isf
on n'a pas mis deux ans pour le
supprimer par contre ces mesures là
elles sont compliquées à mettre en place
le grand reproche c'est surveillé c'est
compliqué en deuxième le symbolique
l'agriculture est à 700 euros a pâti
supprimés ici oui donc pour la poitrine
ya rivière 3 milliards et demi qui a
permis et l'examen pas le montrer plus
dans le même temps de 9 milliards
d'investissements supplémentaires donc
on a perdu 3 pour en gagner 9 à côté de
l'étude sera fait dans quelques mois si
ici qu'il y est c'est fait qu'un impôt
juste héros de steen qui pour une kif
tous les pays leur c'est côté symbolique
tous les autres mais moi je maigris
motors qui inquiète 100 euros vous vous
n'êtes pas là pour le symbole mais
ensuite c'est manuela quand il en a
besoin
de la france et ensuite rappelé bonne
chose li sfc de l'impôt sur l'impôt
parce que les gens qui ont déjà payé la
peau qui voit qu'il ya bien ils ont déjà
payé la peau et on leur fait payer un
impôt sur la fortune tels que c'est
minime est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec jean françois parent quand il dit
que le rythme n'est pas le même et que
le rythme des réformes et roland est ce
que vous l'avez repéré parce que la
retraite à nioro wii s'annonce magique
je vous êtes assez d'accord encore que
j'aimerais savoir comment on peut vivre
avec mu euros enfin aujourd'hui certains
comme fer il faut le faire et c'est très
bien mais jamais dans cet art mois sur
le minimum vieillesse
l'allocation adulte handicapé c'est à
dire que c'est une hausse de 100 euros
une hausse sans précédent depuis 15 ans
alors demain vous fait renverser vous
êtes handicapé vous avez 650 euros
d'allocations monsieur vous vivez avec
659 en gt avec 11000 euros vous votre
salaire de sénateur
venez donc voir si si si 5000 5 500
euros 2006 il évolue et les saveurs et
11000 euros j'ai compté tout est
disponible sur internet d'abord ça fait
partout qui fait que news9 pelage vous
n'attendiez pas la fecafoot il des
contre vérités
attends je reviens dans le rhône et les
alpes aujourd'hui un parlementaire
gagnent aujourd'hui 5 sacks 1905 200
euros mois maintenant les approprient à
la source avec mildred résideront
commission devenait président gracie en
prison en groupe
d'accord mais en même temps et
aujourd'hui l'indemnité parlementaire
je ne peux l'utiliser sous contrôle
aujourd'hui du sénat et de comptables
que pour uniquement des frais comme un
condensé en plus y'a des mallettes 6100
devancé en plus sur 7 sur 7
jean-françois farenc et ensuite j'en
passe
oui l'intériste à des parlementaires
vous parlez de ça vous parlez de verizon
par contre je pense que sur la question
des frais parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya
c'est très important et c'est symbolique
je pense qu'il faudrait qu'ils aient une
transparence merci les prêts des noms
mais je dis depuis peu c'est mieux que
seront publiées grâce à barra essai
oui grâce à la sphère fillon aussi les
choses ont été régularisés il ya plus de
contrôle dans le mental également être
rende compte françois aujourd'hui depuis
le 1er avril
mes dépenses en tant que parlementaire
et de nadine besse que j'ai accès et je
peux consulter les a priori cool elle
est contrôlée par deux organismes
extérieurs extérieur qui monte contrôler
et qui vont contre les 250 sénateur
pendant l'année et qui nous donne qui
nous demandera bientôt commencer ça
c'est pas gênant parlementaires disent
j'ai eu 500 euros des cfd au restaurant
voilà et puis savez j'en ai que ce soit
publiée sur le green catégorie écoutez
moi aujourd'hui je vois bien que les
gens peuvent aller tous à la mairie
publiés vérifiez vérifier l'état de
l'est bien mon patrimoine
g ça fait 35 ans que je fais de la
politique aujourd'hui peuvent aller voir
si je me suis enrichi
je vais les voir vous allez voir une
motion rim les dérange je me suis pas
enrichi tout le monde perd les gens vers
la radio mois plus tôt que m'intéresser
à butt à vos revenus mais moi je vais
m'intéresser un petit peu au revenu des
plus fragiles vous avez parlé
effectivement que les gens qui
travaillent mérite d'avoir d'avoir un
salaire à peu le loisir etc
mais il faut pas oublier une chose c'est
que on est tous on appelle nous appelle
pas parfois les que des cas sociaux
moi j'aime pas ce mot là parce qu'on
peut tous cas sociaux un jour bien sûr
d'un jour à l'autre et là par exemple
vous avez des gens qui travaillent et
qui se fondent et par exemple des
burnout ou les choses comme ça et il se
trouve petit à petit sur une pente qui
les amène directement à avoir comme
durables pour des handicapés parce que
les accidents de travail
on peut faire une rupture d'anévrisme on
peut la boîte ferme
il y en a beaucoup en ce moment malgré
tout parce que la france se
désindustrialise des emplois allez je
termine s'il vous plaît si nous on avait
janvier jeanmaire dans la vie de
terminer d'amour n'avait-on
musée mois alors moi c'est ce que je
voulais dire c'est qu'il faut pas perdre
de vue ces gens là bon c'est des
statistiques il ya trois millions de
gens qui sont à carences alimentaires
etc
moi depuis que je le savais avant
j'étais statistiques mais maintenant
c'est si statistiques ils ont des
visages
elles ont des noms d'appel marc jean
françois etc
je salue et du temps saluer vous les
avez ce que je crains beaucoup c'est que
justement tous ces gens là peut-être
parce qu'à tort on pense que bon elles
vont pas voter où je sais pas et bien
moi ce que j'ai peur c'est que ces gens
là soient oubliées et ça c'est une c'est
pour ça que moi je suis gilet jaune
avant tout alors il ya eu parce que je
ne peux pas être heureux si je vois des
gens dans la misère autour de ma
personne ne peut être heureux s'il ya
des gens dans la bise aux personnes
pourquoi on commence à voir les 9
millions de pauvres en france les plus
riches du monde nomade est d'abord si
pas bien comparer les autres pays n'ont
pas de récolte que ce taux de pauvreté
est l'équivalent dans tous les pays
développés instruments équivalent
partout c'est pour que le système
capitaliste mérite d'être révisés et
d'être tempéré je vous dis comme tel
mais quand on vous dit des mesures pour
les pour regarder aujourd'hui que les
enfants d'abord que tous les enfants
dialecte à la maternelle à 300 que deux
maintenant donne des petits déjeuners à
tous ceux qui n'ont pas mangé chez eux
ce que c'est pas des mesures sociales
déjà que c'est là que ça commence à
l'enfance à l'école ce gouvernement avec
le ministre l'éducation fait les
avancées extraordinaires pour redonner à
chacun une égalité de destin avec la loi
un score supérieur à 99 alors attendez
une égalité de destin vous rendez compte
que c'est pour voir cette opération
nationale même si effectivement c'est
intéressant on pourra leur vouer invités
pour en parler on attendait on va parler
de démocratie et de et de proximité
aussi avec les territoires c'est
important dans la dernière partie de
cette émission mais il ya plusieurs
parlementaires vous n'étiez pas enfin je
vous ai pas entendu le dire françois
patriat plusieurs parlementaires la
reine qui ont dit attendez vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir je dis va y
avoir la mesure whaou
et là tout le monde va dire war est en
fait beaucoup
aujourd'hui ne la trouve pas la mesure
où alors il est ce qu'il ne fallait pas
un moment donné est-ce que c'est elle
évidemment le retour de la sf ou
d'autres mesures
une mesure symbolique forte pour dire le
président de la république vous
as compris même si c'est vrai qu'on est
sur du symbole est-ce qu'il n'y avait
pas ce que vous avez vous qui avez
l'oreille du président de la république
monde le sait dit est ce que vous n'avez
pas un moment donné dit à emmanuel
macron belle l'a peut-être vous devriez
faire ça non parce que je pense que la
mesure où ayew c'est le package c'est
l'ensemble des quinze mesures 15 mesures
qui touchent toutes les couches de la
population qui touche les élus qui
touche les collectivités qui touche la
démocratie qui touche les impôts qui
touche les retraites qui touche l'école
tout ça ça fait une mesure où aoun
globalement alors en matière de réforme
de l'état et de démocratie et de
décentralisation il ya eu beaucoup
d'annoncés du président de la république
mais pas de risque pas de reconnaissance
du vote blanc
j'imagine que tous les deux vous êtes
très déçu mais est ce que vraiment vous
pensez qu emmanuel macron irait jusque
là
non on a toujours un mois très
honnêtement j'avais déjà eu de l'espoir
avant de regarder le discours d'
emmanuel macron en disant que la wii
c'est maintenant ou jamais il nous faut
un truc fort ou sinon enfin voilà on va
continuer les gens sont déterminés et
les gens resteront là tant qu'il est
temps que y
mais vous avez sera pas ça des citoyens
tirés au sort qui vont participer aux
travaux du ceser transition écologique
exclusivement ces assemblées citoyennes
tirés au sort donc on verra dans la
pratique ce que ça donne a priori il
devrait participer aux travaux du
conseil économique social et
environnemental
alors c'est deux choses ils seront tirés
au sort si deux choses différentes
mais pour le pôle rick le vote blanc
donc le vote blanc emmanuel macron
indique le vote blanc ça n'est pas
décidé et ben moi je suis critique
envers sa puisque si c'est décidé qu'on
n'est pas d'accord avec l'existant
s'il n'y a pas de candidat voilà je vous
vois quand j'ai à dire c'est les gens se
déplacent pour aller voter et ne trouve
pas chaussure à leur pied et votre blanc
c'est encore différent de l'abstention
l'abstention c'est enfin voilà pour moi
c'est encore différent donc il aurait pu
octroyer ce vote blanc pour justement
invalidé une élection s'ils votent blanc
était au supérieur à tendre pourcentage
alors et parce qu'ils sont sûrs gaz et
l'excision être qu'à piller des missions
on va pas pouvoir faire le jeu alors je
m'interroge en deux temps je voulais me
répondre sur le rythme serait pour
dessus et bien moi d'abord quand vous
avez dit candidat qui représente 10
sensibilité différente aux élections
nous parmi les dix n'est pas un que vous
mettez encore blanc je propose au gilet
jaune puisque c'est ce qu'il représente
qui devraient être représentées pour pas
qu'ils votent blanc une case présenter
aux élections
c'est tout comme ça ils voteront pour
eux voteront pour l'heure ils voteront
pour leur programme il y aura plus de
votes blancs possibles
deuxièmement le rique l'horeca daudet si
lorik adopté comme tel on vient de
passer 123 120 heures sous la loi pacte
le bloc l'assemblée le sénat ont voté la
loi maintenant adopter écouter notre
temps n'a pas été promu guingamp le
entre temps on demande un rique c'est à
dire que tout ce qu'a fait le parlement
pendant 120 heures qu'il a voté il a
demandé on fait un référendum pour dire
c'est pas une bonne loi n'a nulle non
c'est la négation du parlement et c'est
la négation de la démocratie
représentative qui est le fondement
ceux qui ont essayé la démocratie
directe dans l'antiquité n'ont pas tenus
çà n'a pas alors voilà jean-françois
farenc sur ces questions de l'heure et
démocratie bon le rique bon que le seuil
soit abaissé de 4 millions un million
c'est une c'est bien je pense que si
pétition satire par salle ensuite la
scission jeu quand on lit les moi moi
j'ai lu là j'ai repris sur les sites là
toutes les toutes les propositions du
grand débat c'est très fréquent qu'un
des propositions autour du duric l'idée
de participer à l'élaboration de la loi
est très fréquent moi je pense que
chaque parlementaire il ya des
parlementaires qui l'ont annoncé un qui
mettrait en place un conseil de
circonscription pour discuter avec les
citoyens des projets de loi le faire je
rende vous avez compris que des citoyens
qui veulent pas discuter parce que ça
fait trois mois qu'il discute mais qui
voudrait bien participé à la décision et
quand ces normes et contient un projet
de
à quand un projet de loi ce serait bien
que chaque parlementaire à y rencontrer
face des réunions autour du projet de
loi de manière un petit peu plus
systématique aujourd'hui il est bon il
ya des ils ont leurs bureaux on peut
aller les voir à la permanence fait des
parlementaires mais je pense qu'il faut
qu'il aille beaucoup plus qu'ils sont et
ils ont détecté et vous verrez on vous y
allez l'écouter avec de tous quand on va
voir un député avec avec un problème à
soulever et que le député ou dit de
toute façon je ne remonterai pas vous
perdez un peu fois qua non dans le
système démocratique actuel en fait
alors un moment avant de condamner le
genre de combat de un paquet comme ça de
l'article 68 pour la destitution du
gouvernement
c'est une question et nous te destitué
le gouvernement c'est ce sont des
lettres nommé voce destituer le
président d'éminents par le monde à
supprimer le sénat
j'entends bien on peut avoir une autre
vision de la démocratie participative au
salon vous avez déjà là c'est transformé
notre démocratie on n'a jamais dit qu'on
voulait faire tomber tout tout ne les
changera si présente dans les semaines
qui viennent là le 1er mai il ya
rassemblements on a vu qu'il y avait des
des convergences avec la cgt est ce que
vous allez continuer le mouvement ou est
ce que vous dites bon bah on a essayé de
faire bouger les choses on a fait ce
qu'on a pu et puis voilà en bonne on ne
va pas arrêter un c'est clair j'en ai
discuté hier au camp on était heureux de
solutré des bruits donc non on va pas
s'arrêter là parce que moi pour que je
rentre en amont soit part on assume
petit personnel pour que je rentre il
faut que tout le monde je dis bien tout
le monde ait un minimum mais pas 1000
mhz pas 1000 euros 1 1
un peu plus un plus un peu plus merci
merci voix merci à tous d'avoir échangé
sur ces propositions et de l'avoir
accepté de débattre aujourd'hui merci
c'est comme on paye on va voir on refera
des émissions ne vous inquiétez pas
c'est tout de suite l'essentiel de
l'actualité régionale dans un instant
francis letellier reçoit françois xavier
bellamy tête de liste les républicains
aux élections européennes on vous
souhaite à tous un bon dimanche sur
france 3